how are you doing right now the dazzles
like how is how are you doing because
the look on your face I don't know
the moment you won was kind of like no
really yeah yeah what was going through
your mind shocked honestly I am I just
didn't expect it to the the women in
that category are so phenomenal and very
lucky to be there and be here I know I'm
taking the home who did you forget to
bring because it is not their time it
wasn't your time
I didn't forget I kind of was just like
look guys this isn't the time to come
get your hopes up and this not be it was
my mom and dad yeah talk to him I did
they just pray to them that and would
you say wouldn't they say they just said
they loved me and they were extremely
proud of me so that was nice it's also
like 6 a.m. us up in the UK so they're
probably senses together there's just a
lot of kind of we were thinking about
you and we've got you a gift these might
work in your job there's an agent that
you will need there's a light on it
that's what I'm saying very important
note if you're in Rome in the catacombs
if only we had one of these yes
Tellarites is that what did you say to
Sandra and what did she say to you when
you walk by I think I said I loved her
and I appreciated her cuz honestly this
this whole experience we've gone through
together we believed in the show but we
had no idea how humongous it was gonna
turn out to be and and to kind of have
gone through it with her and she's been
extremely generous on and off screen so
I'm very very grateful of that sometimes
is it crazy though when you stop and you
think this little tiny show and you know
Phoebe is now the toast of the town
there's a tiny show and boom it is
exploring I knew a special because
Phoebe
Pheebs is so so incredible and but it is
crazy I never dreamed that I would be in
this position at all and yeah were you
taking that lady tonight cuz you got to
go where are you taking her
to keep us safe that won't a loser gotta
get her home
yeah I'm a pen cause I got it we got to
here take a blue one in Nicole you owe
me you got a stop if it shows up in the
show you never know right you know we're
not that shows up in the show yeah I'll
make it happen you have connection
congratulations
have fun tonight I will all that you
guys will yes
[Music]
[Applause]